le premier thème c'est la méthode que
nous avons utilisé faire participer les
citoyens dans le cadre de notre
plateforme parlement et citoyens
améliorer potentiellement le texte sur
les sujets qui ne sont pas du tout
évoqué je pense par exemple comment
mieux faire participer les citoyens à la
construction législatif qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui utiliser les nouveaux moyens
numériques en la matière donc nous
voulons aller plus loin que les
propositions gouvernementales qui nous
posent des problèmes sur le fond
notamment sur manifestement un
affaiblissement des pouvoirs du
parlement
nous voulons un pouvoir exécutif fort et
il est fort en ce moment mais aussi un
parlement fort qui soit un véritable
contre pouvoir
justement vous parlez des droits du
parlement comment conserver les droits
du parlement alors qu'on accuse
justement vous venez de le dire le
gouvernement de vouloir les amoindrir le
gouvernement comment on les conserve
le gouvernement veut être efficace je
crois que dans notre pays qui n'est pas
une start up on ne peut pas être
efficace en minorant voir en banalisant
les droits du parlement
le parlement n'est pas un empêchement
tognon il est là pour améliorer les
textes pour faire remonter les
aspirations du terrain regardez ce qui
s'est passé avec la loire ferroviaires
n'ont pas voté mais le temps n'est
peut-être pas celui du temps de l'action
gouvernementale
oui mais l'acteur a le mental c'est cinq
ans c'est pas un an et j'ai le sentiment
qu'on confond vitesse et précipitation
actuellement au niveau de la présidence
de la république et de matignon
les parlementaires n'ont pas besoin de
temps pour retarder les réformes qui
sont parfois utiles mais simplement pour
améliorer leur santé améliorer leur
efficacité
je reprends l'exemple de la sncf s'il
n'y avait pas eu le bicamérisme et la
présence du sénat pensez vous que nous
serions sortis avec un texte qui certes
ne satisfait pas complètement loin de là
mais qui comme meilleur que celui sorti
de la semaine nationale
respectons le parlement et vous verrez
que la démocratie sera renforcé notre
pays je vous pose la question patrick
mairesse que certaines pistes de travail
que vous évoquez aujourd'hui vont être
transmises ensuite au parlement au
gouvernement
bien sûr quand nous évoquons plus
d'égalité homme-femme dans la
constitution quand nous évoquons plus de
place pour le citoyen dans la
constitution nous ferons des amendements
à la réforme constitutionnelle et nous
serons aussi nous opposer à ce qui nous
semble de fausses bonnes idées comme par
exemple la baisse du nombre de
parlementaires en france
justement patrick anna est ce que votre
groupe à ce que vous voterez la réforme
institue celle en tout cas telle qu'on
la connaît aujourd'hui telle qu'elle a
été dévoilé telle qu'elle est non
pourquoi parce que elle est saucissonné
dans l'espace et dans le temps 3 loi
pourquoi ne pas avoir une seule loi y
compris en intégrant la baisse des
parlementaires à l'intérieur de la
réforme constitutionnelle alors qu'elle
est sur une loi organique
aujourd'hui donc c'est quoi cette
volonté de saucissonner la volonté
politique
il faut que les choses soient claires et
pour nous et beaucoup de groupe au sénat
ont la même position nous voulons
examiner
globalement la cohérence de la réforme
et non pas les balles soit 4
gouvernement ce n'est pas le choix est
un choix manifestement tactique et nous
ne sommes pas la tactique voire même
dans la tuyauterie
nous sommes dans l'efficacité et
l'amélioration et la modernisation de
notre république